hi good afternoon thank you all for
being here I'm gonna apologize ahead of
time that you are probably not getting
me at my best
I'm a survivor and watching what has
happened to dr. Christy buzzy Ford has
meant a lot and very hard for me today
and I'm sure for many of you so that
said if you need some moments to
yourself I would be happy for you to
take this time instead of listening to
me to find a quiet place and recenter I
won't be offended I see you and I
support you and you're not alone
okay my name is Erica joy Baker as Alex
just said some of you may know me online
is Erica joy but I can assure you my
last name is Baker not joy I have worked
in tech for nearly two decades
sorry so I've worked in tech for nearly
two decades beginning as a Windows
system administrator at the University
of Alaska and winding my way through
Home Depot and Google and slack to light
at patreon where I'm currently an
engineering manager my first programming
language is basic my most recent is
Python so I hoped alone hope to learn go
real soon now once I have some free time
I grew up taking things apart and
putting them back together again
I was the person who set the clock on
the VCR at my house I was in person to
install the cd-rom drive in my computer
and upgrade our computer to a shocking 1
gigabyte hard drive what are we gonna do
with all that space I was the one who
knew a jumper settings fuse and I knew
how to tell DOS to do the right thing
when Windows booted I spent much time
trolling on dog net and ethnic shout-out
to people who know IRC and I was one of
the first people to do to use that
newfangled World Wide Web thing when
Netscape Navigator came out I had a Geo
sales page in an angel fire page and a
tripod page and I was on a social
network that existed well before a
facebook or myspace and on that network
I taught thousands of people how to use
HTML in the glory days of pseudonymous
web usage I'm not going to tell you what
my handle was because then you'd go look
it up and that'd be weird
I prefer VI over Emacs got my first text
editors notepad all Emacs people are
scowling at me right now
I have no database preferences really
but if I don't say don't use Mago my
friend Kyle will probably yell at me so
there don't use [ __ ] I've said it Kyle
don't hurt me I used to be really
excited about react because I was super
excited about geospatial clearing and
how it could apply to my passion of
genealogy research and solving the
world's family trees but the fun fact
that is what I actually love in this
world Tech just allows me to do that I
like finding edge and corner case bugs
and figuring out how to fix them my
favorite shell is this and I'm sharing
all that because most of you know me as
that lady who talks about diversity to
inclusion all the time I won't shut up
about it it's a subject I'm really
passionate about but maybe most of you
don't know that I'm a dyed-in-the-wool
spent my lunch hour reading books at my
locker specific specifically the rainbow
books
anybody knows what those are any
freaker's any audience only at 3:00
history y'all but ya spent my lunch
hours Reading Rainbow books at my locker
in high school I just don't talk about
it much I think they're a lot more
interesting things to talk about besides
my nerdery but there I've said it
it's on the record I smell I'm a lot of
time talking about diversity and
inclusion and not technical stuff
because there are a lot of people in
this world many of you in this room who
can talk about technical stuff and I'll
let you do it and I will talk about the
diversity inclusion stuff because there
are fewer people doing that and that's
super important especially right now in
the world I'm passionate about talking
about that specifically and largely
because the idea that an entire industry
should belong to one or two types of
people who then get to be the
gatekeepers for that industry is
preposterous and ridiculous on its face
there are a slew of other reasons I'm
passionate about diversity inclusion and
normally that's what I'd be onstage
talking about today but I'm going to
talk about something different today I
want to talk about changing the world so
I'm gonna start by reading you some
actual quotes that I got from the actual
internet
innovative data solutions companies on
pace to change the world
The Economist autonomous vehicles will
change the world
Google for entrepreneurs creates
campuses physical hubs where
entrepreneurs can learn connect and
build companies that will change the
world
OtterBox grows to give back inspiring
kids to change the world through
entrepreneurship and philanthropy
Microsoft was founded on the belief that
software can change the world and random
acts of kindness is a shining example of
how we can all come together to make a
difference Google's made with code is
proud to partner with Technovation
challenge to inspire young woman to
change the world as the creator of the
first-ever on-demand service for
designated drivers CEO Evan Stafford is
on an ambitious mission to change the
world Mixpanel
the leader in mobile analytics has
announced that their second data-driven
conference has sold out for those
interested in learning how technology's
best and brightest are using data to
change the world
mix panel will host a live stream import
i/o enables customers to tap into the
power of data to change the world dfj is
a venture capital firm that partners
with extraordinary entrepreneurs who set
out to change the world
slang is universal and could be the
driving factor that brings us together
and one day possibly change the world
said Edwin Benton CEO and founder of
slangin friends it seems like everyone
wants a change of world from big tech
companies to little startups how many of
you have worked at a start-up in your
entire career like lots of you how many
of you have heard at one point while
working in the startup some version of
we want to change the world yeah it's
pretty common if you haven't heard it
before
odds are you're going to hear it at some
point in your working life and friends
fellow computing comrades I am so
pleased to announce to you today that we
did it
we changed the world we created the
tools of modern revolutions we've helped
give platforms to folks who didn't have
them previously we changed how many
people travel from point A to point B we
changed where people stay on vacation we
changed how they communicate how they
date how they eat how they create how
they get news how they play games how
they do laundry how they exercise how
they buy furniture how they design with
that furniture how they find housing how
they get paid how they get medical care
how they do pretty much everything
mission accomplished
in the words of George Bush we changed
the world
and now we're gonna have to do it again
because see we neglected to do one major
important thing we did not finish the
statement we did not say how we want to
change the world we did not say in what
ways we wanted to change the world we
just said we wanted to change the world
the result was that we ended up the
change in the worlds and weighed the
world in ways we didn't think about we
ended up changing the world in ways we
didn't expect and building a better
surgeon
we built an ad targeting mega machine
setting that up as the norm for
generating website revenue to build
better ad targeting we bit began sucking
up every little bit of information we
could get about people whether they
wanted us to or not and trying to
connect everyone we built tools of mass
harassment and trying to better reach
out to people we might like to hire we
built a legitimate legitimized doxy
machine every one of you who's ever
gotten one of those emails from a
recruiter that you're like how in the
world you get my email address duk-soo
just you know for-profit a better way to
share pictures came with increased focus
on curating the best versions of oneself
with everyone else trying to live up to
those unrealistic images better phones
and access to the Internet resulted in
greater disconnection and loneliness and
trying to build better social networks
to rebuild those feelings of connection
and belonging we lost we built great
propaganda machines that are easily
manipulable
by major by major nation states to
effectively influence an election such
that the most qualified person we've
ever had run for president lost to a
charlatan not worth his weight in
feathers sorry not sorry
we got so focused on disruption that we
didn't stop to think about who or what
we were disrupting so we need to start
over and finish the statement we want to
change the world for the better for
everybody and that friends is where
things get a little more complicated so
let's do a little history in the
beginning there were nerds well in the
beginning there was the government
really and bailed Bell Labs in the
government IBM a little bit I know but
let's not go that far back let's go back
to say 1958 and the small business
investment Act of 1958 that Act was
passed and it allowed the US Small
Business Administration to license small
business investment companies to help
the financing and management of the
small entrepreneurial businesses in the
United States go us in short the act is
how we got venture capitalists in the
early days VC VC firms are making their
money on electronic medical and data
processing tech which is what the first
venture-backed startup being Fairchild
Semiconductor hands if you know that is
yeah y'all know your history Silicon
Valley was arguably founded by the
people who founded Fairchild
Semiconductor
you can think for Moore's law Intel and
your favorite VC kleiner perkins so you
could say that Silicon Valley was
created with venture capital money
venture capital money continued to
finance Silicon Valley tech being fueled
by private equity funds and limited
partnerships though the amounts of money
were tiny in comparison to what we see
today that changed 1978 when corporate
pension funds were pivoted permitted to
invest in privately held companies which
allowed the VC industry to raise roughly
three billion dollars in today's dollars
so it was 750 million back then VC was
flush of cash and they used it to bring
us dec Apple engine in tech the success
of small number of the small number of
early VC firms resulted in everyone
trying to get in on the action and by
the end of the 1980s there were 600 BC
firms 650 VC firms actually and that's
comparison to the few dozen that began
in might in there
if you haven't seen the TV show halt and
catch fire
I highly recommend it it's a great look
at this time period and it's a great
show starring Mackenzie Davis who is
amazing
the night aggress at the end of the 80s
bc returns were low no small thanks to
the market tanking in 1987 this caused a
number of vc firms to shrink again and
in the early 90s with the surviving
firms strengthening their portfolio
companies Bill Clinton became president
the market recovered and money was
flowing again
yeah Democrats which had brought us that
VC boom of the mid to late 90s and while
VC was booming so was tech talking fast
this is a lot in 1972 the company
truffaut data was born to track and
analyze traffic data a couple of the
founders of traffic data used the
information they learned working on that
to found Microsoft's Microsoft took
relatively little funding in comparison
to others and around this time mosaic
bredis Netscape Navigator which was
founded amongst other by Marc Andreessen
and we got the World Wide Web
Netscape brought us JavaScript 10 days
10 days in 1995 and also brought us
Brendan Eich who went on to found the
brave browser and also fun prop 8 but I
digress again the 90s brought us all
manner tech much too much of it backed
by VC who remembers pets.com yeah and
then it all fell down the Nasdaq crashed
in 2000 the ripples hit the VC industry
companies couldn't IPO anymore
valuations plummeted and many funds were
underwater and the VC industry had and
how many of you were here for the first
com crush solidarity it was brutal it
was brutal for us and it was brutal for
the VCS those who were around during
that crash never want to feel that pain
again and the VCS who around don't want
to feel the pain of watching their
massively overvalued investments lose
all their values seemingly overnight
they want companies of today it's a May
money I tell you all this to underscore
the point that Silicon Valley is venture
capital have you ever heard the story of
the Scorpion and the Frog if you haven't
it goes a little something like this
scorpion esta frog to take it across the
river frog box nope not gonna do it
you're gonna sting me
scorpion rip is offended how dare you I
would never and after much convincing
the Frog agrees to take the scorpion
across the river halfway across scorpion
stings of frog as the fraud is dying he
says to the scorpion how could you you
said you wouldn't sting me too much the
Scorpion replied what did you expect I'm
a scorpion it's what I do venture
capital is represented on the boards of
nearly every 10th company that has taken
VC funding so while the founders of
every tech company that has taken that
funding might have idealistic notions of
change in the world the people they
answer to have one goal make money and
if they're lucky spawned more companies
that they can invest in to make more
money the VCS are the Scorpions from the
story of the Scorpion in the Frog in
case I wasn't clear if they say I want
to help you change the world there is a
silent as long as you're making this
money that goes along with it and if you
aren't making them money
well they'll sting you to the tune of
asking you from your company and
replacing you with someone who will make
the money and worry less about changing
the world they'll go ahead and slap some
ads on it's awesome customer data and
make some deals with the lowest of the
low
as long as it's making money ok that's a
lot there is hope I promise
we the makers the builders the creators
the designers the developers developers
developers the researchers the aspires
and the strivers can really change the
world starting right at home I'll give
you the formula just have to do it
step one have an idea make sure the idea
you have does not violate any agreements
you have with your employer should you
have one step to work on your idea own
on your own personal computer that is in
no way attached to your current current
employer
should you have one grow your ideas
slowly slowly the obsession with hyper
growth was scaling up a company rapidly
getting as me customers as fast as
possible comes from where the B C's we
don't need that get customers get some
paying customers it's more of them keep
going build what you want to build on
your own terms that's how you do it it's
pretty basic and yeah I know it's really
basic but I feel like we could all use
that reminder from time to time that we
don't have to sacrifice our ideals and
our beliefs to change the world we can
build companies that are sustainable
that grow without the VC funding that
make us obsessed with growth hyper
growth we can make choices they're the
best interests of our customers and that
don't sacrifice our values on the altar
of growth but don't sell out what we
know is right for the almighty dollar or
your chosen currency take MailChimp
I think MailChimp is a sponsor so yay
from the ashes of the dot-com bust
MailChimp was born in 2001 now 17 years
later they're bringing in over half a
billion dollars in revenue with no VC
funding which is almost unheard of but
just goes to show you that it's possible
they grew slowly and sustainably and are
now able to employ nearly a thousand
people across three cities they did not
try to get rich quick which is one of
the many lies that VCS try to get you to
believe about working attacked by late
and sure some folks will get comfortable
faster than their peers and get rich
quick earth but that's only a small
percentage of folks in the industry if
we think of our work in tech as careers
instead of gold rushes where we're
always fighting to have the next big
payout the next big IPO the next big
whatever we can work more thoughtfully
on how we change the world instead of
IPOs and public relations we can change
the world with a different sort of PR
one pull request at a time at every
moment we have to ask ourselves I can do
this
but should I do this and when that
answer is no we not being driven by the
urgent race to growth can do the right
thing when a PM from another team starts
pushing on you to give access to phone
numbers you got for security purposes
Facebook so they can target those phone
numbers for ads you can tell them no and
you can tell them why you can be the
person who fights for the user customer
sometimes that fight means you leave the
company but sometimes that's what you
have to do and shout-out to the people
who have left their companies recently
because they found their companies doing
horrible despicable things I see you and
I support you too
ultimately how we're going to change the
world is by the legacy we leave behind
whether we found companies and projects
or we work our way up in someone else's
letters what we build will have some
effect on the world and by build I don't
just mean products I mean companies -
we're at the beginning of the a IVR and
machine learning revolutions we are
building not just the products but the
companies that will power tomorrow and
it is extremely important that those
companies represent everyone I said I
was not going to talk about diversity
but I guess I was wrong
see not only is the idea that an
industry can that that an industry can
be the sole domain of one or two types
of people completely ridiculous on its
face having an industry like that is the
result a systemic racism and sexism
rampant in the environment that the
industry was born in and is a surefire
way to continue that systemic racism and
sexism cyclical I mean let's go back to
the beginning where we change the world
the wrong way one example I didn't call
out was how we build algorithms and
models that reinforce and pepper
perpetuated our own biases stereotypes
and beliefs the classic example should
tell the story enough if you feed a
system data that shows over the past six
years where black people have been
arrested than white people in the United
States that system will learn that black
people are more likely to commit crimes
and white people that system has no idea
that the data you just fed it is the
result of a history of racism that
allows white people to be arrested more
often for crimes of lesser significance
so we're clear this is not scare
mongering the system exists and it is in
place and in use to help judges
determine sentences for those who commit
crimes today and now I can't guarantee
you that had a black person been in the
room when those algorithms were being
created or written or tested that that
person would have spoken up given that
it's hard to speak up when you know it's
going to come at personal cost but I can
tell you that they probably
would have thought about it and this is
why we must build companies that
represent everyone and all experiences
so that when we're building the future
we're not making of reinforcing the same
mistakes of our racist sexist and all
kinds of other bigoted pests that is how
we really change the world
so that was a lot of doom and gloom and
since things lately have been very do me
and gloomy enough let me just say this
our industry has brought many wonderful
things as well
my first experience connecting with
people online give me a window into
experiences that weren't like mine I
learned what life was like for a young
white man who lived an entire continent
continent away in Alabama who's here
from Alabama one person in the deep
south who had had a daughter and was
struggling how to figure out how to
raise a family for no other reason but
the internet what I have had a reason or
opportunity to connect with him and we
formed a friendship that lasted this day
over two decades later in fact I'll
probably see him probably at Christmas
when I go to Alabama to visit my
partner's family for him and for
everyone else in the chatroom that I
went to shout out to Blues Traveler chat
I was just another person that they
talked to they did not see my skin color
they would not have known my gender had
I not told them I just knew what my very
embarrassing chosen by a 15 year old
handle was
we shared ideas we formed friendships we
had relationships and I'm not sure that
would happen today
as I alluded to earlier I've been all
over the internet in the last 20 years
and I've watched the internet change and
grow I've watched you internet become
less of a place where you can connect
with anyone no matter who they are and
where they're from but instead a place
for you to find people to hate and find
disagreements with that pullets words
hate that pulled towards being are worth
sub where somes online disappoints me
because we have the makings of what
could be a beautiful world in our hands
we just use it the right way for example
though Twitter has become a distributed
harassment system it connected many
people who were seeking to find a
community in its early days that was
what Twitter was meant to do have a
thought to build tools in to handle
abuse and harassment early on it could
easily be what Blues Traveler chat was
for me over 20 years ago an excellent
way to find community to connect with
people who to connect people who aren't
like each other so that they may learn
from one another with the added bonus of
amplifying voices of those who
previously hadn't had platforms but had
important messages like serrata Burke
with a meaty movement or the women who
founded the black lives matter movement
movements that are right now changing
the world we can bring this change we
can change the world for the better
we can build systems that help people
find therapists shout out to therapy
which is wonderful I would not be here
today without finding and going to
I would not be here today without
finding and going to therapy in 2014 and
I make sure that I say that in every
talk because I want everybody to know
that therapy is available to them most
of us make a lot of money and have good
benefits and we can go to therapy and
work our stuff out it's magic ok back on
track
we can build systems that help Flint get
clean water we can build systems that
educate that inform that connect we can
build systems that help solve inequity
and educational systems we can build
systems that alert when people are being
unfairly treated for being different we
can build systems where everyone is
represented and has the same
opportunities for success and growth
growth we can do all these things and
change the world
but first we must undo the changes we
made so this is my call to action for
you because I know a lot of people
really love a call to action in a talk
here it is if you work at a company that
you know is doing something harmful that
you've averted your eyes from and now is
your time to speak up and say something
and to do something is a now-or-never if
you say since that they're paying equity
is within your company maybe start a
spreadsheet you can speak up about it
until someone hears you if you know that
your company is misusing user data you
can easily share your story with someone
who will blow that whistle for you if
you need to protect your employment I
see if you the folks who can't just quit
their job because they have people to
support I value you too if you know your
company is making deals with those who
will put people in harm's way or is
building a better way to kill people or
is censoring people or is selling
information to the highest bidder
or is unfairly unfairly treating people
with power such that they get to skirt
the rules or something like that
now is the time to speak up tear down
the negative changes we made to the
other people to make other people rich
so that we can build up the world in a
way that is more kind more equitable and
more just if you take away one thing
from this talk I want it to be this
change the world just make sure you're
changing for the better thank you for
the time today believe survivors have
America
[Applause]